Millie Bobby Brown turned 16 today and
the actress has a lot to get off her
chest I've been you know following the
news and everything that's going on
right now and I felt that it needed to
be said she's using the special occasion
to speak out about the harsh realities
of growing up in the spotlight the
birthday girl shared a video to
Instagram that included a mash-up of
negative headlines about her along with
Justin Bieber's song changes I'm going
through changes though I'm going through
changes don't mean that
age change is what Millie emphasized in
her caption next to the video she says
quote I feel like change needs to happen
for not only this generation but the
next hour our world needs kindness and
support in order for us children to grow
and succeed the last few years haven't
been easy
I'll admit that there are moments I get
frustrated from the inaccuracy
inappropriate comments sexual ization
and unnecessary insults that ultimately
have resulted in pain and insecurity for
me but not ever will I be defeated the
stranger things at risk goes on to say
quote let's focus on what needs changing
and I hope this video informs you on the
things that go on behind the scenes of
the headlines and flashing lights
don't worry I'll always find a way to
smile young people can have their moment
and you know really break kind of like
the standard Millie got a lot of love
from her celeb friends like co-star
Noah snap Bella Hadid and Yara Shahidi
since taking on the role of eleven in
the Netflix series stranger things in
2016 Millie has experienced a ton of
success including an Emmy nomination for
Outstanding Supporting Actress in a
Drama at the age of 13 through it all
the young star has managed to keep a
level head here's what she told ET in
2018 I'm very grateful I think so many
things are happening all at once but you
know you just stick to the same things
that same friend same people same
bedsheets all that we're not doing
diamonds up in this no I mean unless
it's like get you know and that's like
you need to go into like a booking
reservation for a restaurant then you're
like maybe just drop the name but
anything else no nothing else I mean I'm
a very grounded person except for when
you want to get into Maggiano's
[Music]